foreign
just said I do it's unbelievable that's
right Taylor Lautner and Taylor Dome are
officially married the couple tied the
knot on Friday during a ceremony at the
Epic Estate Winery outside of Paso
Robles California the lovebird said
their vows in front of 100 of their
closest friends and family the groom in
a traditional black tuxedo the bride in
a gorgeous white gown with a long train
and veil with their respective wedding
parties by their side the biggest thing
I would tell myself is uh to soak up
each and every moment ahead of the big
day Dome shared these mirror selfies
from her pre-wedding celebration rocking
a red corset and a veil
the two were first introduced by the
actor sister McKenna Moore and made
their love Insta official in October
2018. it's a new fun thing for me a few
years later the couple announced that
they were engaged sharing a series of
snaps from the romantic proposal the
Twilight star writing 11 11 2021 and
just like that all of my wishes came
true everything has been leading up to
this Dome shared the same pics to her
own account alongside the caption my
absolute best friend I cannot wait to
spend forever with you and her man well
he swooped into the comments of that
post with a sweet message got news for
you the feeling is mutual right yeah
it's true following the news of their
engagement Lautner was all smiles
talking about the exciting Milestone
with E.T we're super excited so we
haven't started any sort of planning
um we're kind of really just soaking
this all in
um so we're gonna take it one day at a
time but I I could not be happier I feel
so blessed
[Music]